for our rebellion to succeed King's
Landing had to be taken forcefully no
one was foolish enough to believe that
Eris was gonna hand his crown over
peacefully the mad Kings reign needed to
end what Tywin Lannister's forces did
was unfortunate but it was necessary to
secure the Iron Throne and bring peace
and justice to the Seven Kingdoms my
glorious victory at the Trident left me
wounded but I sent my personal maester
to attend to sir Barristan Selmy instead
his wounds were more severe even though
sir Barristan was a member of Eris's
Kingsguard and fought on the opposing
side that man's bravery and loyalty was
something to behold but this meant my
wounds would take longer to heal and I
couldn't ride to King's Landing myself I
sent the one man I trusted over anyone
else in this world Ned Stark in my place
had I been able to ride perhaps I could
have reached King's Landing sooner and
prevented some of the violence that
occurred when the Lannisters entered the
city still what Lord Tywin did was for
the greater good even what happened to
princess Elia and her children babies
all know theirs was the same cursed
blood that flowed within the mad Kings
veins they were dragon spawn and
couldn't be allowed to survive what
would they grow to be loyal subjects Ned
with his damned northern armor he and I
had our first major fight over the
deaths of the Targaryen children Ned
called it murder murder
it was war it was war Lord Stark
demanded that the Lannisters be held
responsible for their crimes was it a
crime to put an end to a family of
lunatics born of incest I wouldn't and
still won't blame Tywin instead I sent
Ned Stark south to finish off the
remaining Targaryen loyalists it was
only lyanna stark's death that
reconciled us Ned had lost his sister I
had lost my betrothed and beloved we
shared that sad bond together Ned and I
through it our friendship was made
strong again as for the mad Kings
surviving heirs those that were able to
scurry away in the face of my fury now
live somewhere across the Narrow Sea
they had best stay there if they ever
set foot in Westeros again they will
face the King's justice